WE GET THINGS UNDERWAY AND NET,O
STUFF IT IN!
THE SAVE IS MADE.
A PENALTY MOV
SNIPES IT  ONE.
IN MY ESTIMATION, LOOKING AT UP.
>>
IMPROVED ON SINC
DANAULT BATTLES IN THE CORNER,
RETRIEVES THE IT TO DOUGHTY.
DOUGHTY, ONE-TIMER.OFF OF QUICK.
IT IS A SECOND P AND
QUICK EXTENDS THE RIGHT PAD TO
GET A PIECE OF THAT CLEAR
PA
IMPORTANT, BECAUSEA SHOT IS SAVY
KINGS ARE ON THE BOARD!
DUSTIN BROWN PICKS UP
PAD.
THAT CORNER..
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THE
>>, REDIRECT PLAY!
GOODODA SHOT, STICK SAVE KAMARIE
REBOUND CONTROL.
NOT WERE SAROS WANTS TO GO.
HE MAKES ONE SAVED BY THEHE OPE.
OFF THE SIDE OF THE NET ON THE
SE
POWER PLAY GASN'T DRAMATIC.
IT WAS MORE "GET THE SHOT,
ARVIDSSON ON THAT SIDE OF THE
NET --HE SMOTHERS THAT IT AHEAD.
THEY WILL GET T WORK INITIALLY,T
WORKS AT THE END. BEATS COVID T.
REBOUND, SAVE, REBOUND AGAIN